- Growing up with the wrong information,
growing up with role
models as family members.
In the ghetto, you know, in the hood,
we had this certain lingo that we spoke on
and everything that I was taught
from a early age was all bad.
But in a sense it was good because
our conversations were about
getting over on the system.
But I'm like, what system is that?
And the system was being
poor, black and in the ghetto.
That was our prison kinda saying,
that was our training ground.
And I remember
being 14, 15.
You know, the older guys telling me,
my older role models.
Yeah, man, get in as much trouble
as you can before you turn
18, 'cause once you turn 18,
you're gonna hit the county
and once you get there, man, it's just
a whole 'nother level.
Now, they painted this picture of prison
being like Camp Snoopy, you
know, we had the weights,
they had the TV, they had
cigarettes, they had coffee.
So to me, it was like going on adventure,
say going to the amusement
park, like a Magic Mountain
or an Oxbury Farm, that's
the way I depicted prison
back then even though I'd
never been there because
it was the picture that was painted to me.
Made it so alluring, it's
like, oh, man, I can't wait
to experience that and...
Not knowing that
it'd be one of those kind of...
Home away from homes that
just, completely, just engulfed
me, man and it kinda had me
messed up in more ways than one.
First time I went to prison,
I had a lot of stuff going on, you know,
in my life at the time
and I needed a break.
So, I think I was sentenced to 16 months.
16 with half, for strong armed robbery.
And I did 10 months and a couple weeks.
But they had sent me to Fire
Camp and I was fighting fires
and what an adventure that
was, man, being in a cabin,
being in the mountains,
you know, away from society
and no barbed wire fence, no guard towers
or nothin' like that.
Eatin' like a king and
being on the front line
fighting fires, that was
a hell of an adventure
and that was the first
impression I got from prison.
That was it, you know,
I came in looking like Alfalfa
and I came home looking like The Rock.
In 10 months, man.
That transformation just took
place and I was like, oh man,
it's everything they said
it was plus more, prison.
You know but I didn't
even know at the time
and I was in prison in my own mind,
body and spirit, prior to going there.
And the cold thing about it
is I was looking at that,
looking at that part
as a release, you know,
and everything, things were
hard on the streets and I
couldn't maintain, I couldn't
handle, I knew where to go
to find that release to get
that pressure up off of me,
you know, dealing with the things
that were going on in the 80s.
You know, the 80s were the
roughest part of my life.
You know, I can't stand the 80s.
What I went through, what I
experienced and being exposed
to in the 80s, you know, with everything
that was going on in the
neighborhood back then.
And
the 80s.
Man, I couldn't wait to escape, man.
And I found a way out, you know?
I do know it was the
wrong way, but yet, still,
I found a way out from
dealing with that bullshit
family situation, from dealing
with the crack epidemic
and from dealing with that
gang stuff that was going on.
Man, it was all these different
things going on in my life
at the time and I just didn't
know how to deal with it.
For the life of me, I just couldn't.
I couldn't fathom
growing up in a predicament that I was in.
And just saw myself
drowning in quick sand.
You know, at the same
time and looking around
and couldn't see no help.
There was no help for me
back then and I knew it.
Shit, I knew I was in deep trouble.
And that shit kinda hurt me.
And so...
My second trip to prison,
I did another strong armed robbery
and they gave me four years.
Once again, I went to Fire Camp, so.
I go through the PFT
and all that kinda stuff
and I excelled at the
exercise, to the jumping jacks
to running the mile and
the pull ups and the dips
and all that and mind
you, they had weights.
And once again, the second time
I turned up in prison, you know,
I was looking like Alfalfa.
You know, scrawny,
skinny, 155 soaking wet.
And I think I did 27 months on that joke.
And I came out like
220, fuckin' huge, man.
Lookin' like a action
hero, for real, you know?
'Cause I didn't even look real to myself.
And then when I used to
see, encounter people
on the streets like my family, they said,
"My God, Eric, you know,
man, what happened?"
Shit, I don't know, your
guess as good as mine.
I guess it was that good
eatin', fightin' the fires,
being in the best shape of my life.
Then my 20s, as I was going through that
experience with the prison,
now, mind you,
my first impression was
Fire Camp, eating good,
making good money and not
being around no guards
and all that kinda stuff,
no walls, no barbed wire.
But as I kept going back
and forth, it started
getting worser and worser and worser.
And I think my third time they
didn't send me to Fire Camp
because my points had rose
because of the two prior
trips of going to prison.
Now, I have five prior commitments
and I have about
15, let's call it 15
parole violations.
You know, one year,
seven months, this, that.
And but on my third time,
man, I didn't go to Fire Camp.
They said I didn't qualify for it because
my case was a serious violent.
So back in this time they had
the three strikes going on.
They had all these laws coming up
and things were slowly
changing in the system, man.
And I didn't really notice
it until it was too late.
But by the time I came
to the realization about
the changes that was
going on in prison, man,
I was already lost in the sauce.
You know, and what I mean by that
is they start taking things away.
They start making it where it wasn't fun
no more and wantin' to go to prison.
You know, I mean, I got
to the level three yard.
It was way different than Fire Camp.
You had, I was in a cell,
living with a celly.
They had the barbed wire, the gun towers
and no warning shots
and all that bullshit,
so that was like a culture shock to me.
Because I was used to
Camp Snoopy, Disneyland.
And my reality was far from that.
It wasn't no more Disneyland,
there wasn't no more Camp Snoopy.
You know, it was where you
really had to be on your
Ps and Qs, man, it wasn't no
guarantee you'll make it home.
And I was like, goddamn,
you got to be kidding me.
Ain't no, no, there they
ain't no guarantee, not here.
You know, and for the first time
I got to see the difference in how
the longer people stay in
prison, say the lifers,
they come home, you know,
they got more stuff going on.
Now for me, I think when
I went there, I probably
had maybe three years, they sentenced me
to three years for a gun
that didn't belong to me.
And I think I was home for two days only.
And I went back, two days on
the streets, went right back
and that's when they sent
me to that level three
for the first time.
And I never knew anything about PTSD.
But I understand being
in prison, it's that
kinda thing that goes on in there.
Now, while you in there you got
to stay on top of your game.
You got to use your A game.
You got to stay with your race.
They got the prison politics bullshit
going up in there so you got to play that
and most importantly, you
got to stay out of trouble.
You know, you've got to
learn how to do your program
but stay out of the way of
others and that's not easy
because there's always something
that's liable to happen
in prison beyond your
control, like the riots,
lock downs, modified programs
and so it was dangerous.
Now, I remember, say my four, fifth
trip going back and forth,
it didn't dawn on me that
I experienced something
worse than being on the streets
with my bout with the crack,
with the environment and
everything that came with that.
Now, that was a heavy burden
to carry on the streets
because being addicted ain't no joke.
And so I remember coming from prison,
coming home, I don't give
a damn how long I was gone
and then ended up in the same spot where
I left out at fuckin' with that crack.
I'm like, how the fuck I get here?
Because in that other place it was worser
but in a different way.
You know, I had to...
It's like going to the military bootcamp.
I had to gear up and be
prepared, mind, body and spirit
for this prison war kinda
setting, not the jungle war
but the prison, the concrete
war, the concrete jungle.
And now, that's what prison was, man.
You know, you had these races up in there
and you know, everybody
stays separate and all that
bullshit and you know, they
had everything set up, man.
And you know, we had our own
separate tables and, you know,
it's like going back in
the motherfuckin' 60s, man.
Where we had the colored
drinking fountain and the white.
That's what it feel like in prison.
Mexicans sat at they motherfuckin' table.
We had our two or three,
the whites had theirs.
I'm like, man, you know, we
can interact with each other.
But you know, there was
lines that you couldn't cross
in there, you know, or
there was some consequences.
So, you know,
the more I was goin', the more I got wise
to the intertwinings
of the prison setting.
And most importantly, the
most important factor, man,
that I missed was not seeing
it as a plantation, man,
as the...
(Eric stammering)
I started in '87, you know,
going to prison and everything.
But I never looked at it as
going to a slave plantation
until later on, man, because
the more I kept going back
and forth, the more I
started reading books,
making inquiries and really
taking a look around,
they have 34 prisons in California alone
and a majority of 'em
set up of men of color.
And that's the God's honest
truth and if I didn't go
so many motherfuckin'
times, I wouldn't know that.
But my experience tells
me that 'cause I done been
to about 15 different
prisons in California alone.
Doing my 19 trips.
You know, it was fun at the beginning
but in the end, it wasn't fun no more.
Wasn't nothing funny
about going to prison,
not when reality set in.
Shit, but I was already,
it was too late for me.
I was already entangled in that shit.
And for the life of me, I
couldn't find my way out of it.
And so what happened was, the more
I was going back and forth and seeing
that it wasn't all cracked up
what it was supposed to be.
It still didn't dawn on me,
man, because I was always
looking at prison as
my home away from home,
which in turn, became my home from home.
Because I did more time in
prison than I did on the streets
during my 20s and my 30s.
And I think the last time
I went in, I went in at 43
and I came out at 50, I'm 53 right now.
But my last trip I did
about six and a half,
close to seven years, man.
And that was my last bout with visiting,
you know, my home away from home here.
And well, I'd just like
to share something about
the prison setting, man,
and how it was set up.
And so I'm looking at it as
a way to escape my reality
on the streets but it was at
the point where, I think in...
They saw where we were benefiting
from the coffee, from the
cigarettes, from the weights
and the guards were getting
scared of us because
we would go in scrawny and come out
like the Incredible Hulk.
You know, and I paid witness
to that, man, I think
on my trip when I did four with half, man,
I came out so huge, I looked
like Arnold in his prime.
Fuckin' cut, man, ripped, arms swole.
Blew my mind and that's
what I used to look forward
to by going to prison, was
those kinda experiences.
Let aside the race riots
and all that other bullshit.
My whole thing was if I end up in prison,
I know what Ima do.
Ima abide by the rules and the guidelines.
Ima be the model motherfuckin'
inmate and I'm gonna get on
swole and try this bullshit
on the streets again.
Not knowing that I was
bringing some of the bullshit
from the prison setting out
on the streets were compacted.
I couldn't succeed on the
streets because I took the shit
from the streets that I endured
to get to prison thinking
I'm escaping and just added
some more stuff to the equation
that had nothing to do with
the streets but the prison,
kinda, bylaws and guidelines and I brought
that shit to it and it just didn't work.
It didn't work.
So what I learned on the streets,
that shit don't work in prison.
And what I learned in prison,
it doesn't work on the streets.
It's two different settings,
man, it's two different.
I didn't know it at the time.
So what happened was...
I got caught up in the...
And the just knowing that
once I got to prison, I know
it wasn't gonna be all good.
By four but I knew it wasn't
gonna be all bad either.
So in 1987, excuse me, 1990,
I started in 87, so 10 years into it.
1997, they took the weights off the yard.
They went from taking all the
heavy stuff and leaving us
so much, like they say
they take the 150 dumbbells
down to the 100 to the 95s and the 80s.
They leave us the 75s on down.
They take all the extra
quarters and they rolled
a 50 and a 25, 75 only for the bench.
So they took the majority
of weights and left us
very little to work with
because they said we were just
coming home too big and
the guards were, the guards
were more, they weren't in shape.
They weren't at the top of they game.
You know, being a prison guard, you just
go there to do your thing and go home.
So they wasn't tripping
on trying to be in shape.
A few were health conscious,
but the majority of the prison
guards there, they're just
there to do the job, man
and goin' home, collect they
pay, I'm not mad at 'em.
So they took the weights.
They took the majority of
the heavy, the extra stuff
and right behind that, they took
all the weights off the yard.
Right up under our noses,
they just came one day
with some trucks and they
had these inmates come, man,
and they just took
everything off the yard, man.
It took them maybe two days
and they had us on modified program.
You know, we just went and
eat and went back to our dorms
because they didn't want
us around that while
it was taking place, man,
until they were done.
And it took two days for
them to take everything off
the yard, I didn't see it
at the time as a deterrent
to keep people from wanting
to come back and forth.
I couldn't see it back
then but they was trying
to come up with different
methods so yo ass
wouldn't wanna come to prison no more.
They didn't wanna make it
easy, wanna make it look
like Camp Snoopy which it was back then.
They said, well, you know,
guys don't mind coming in
and out, they don't mind
coming back and forth because
of the set up, the layout.
And so they started with the weights.
Now, what's most important
in prison is weights,
coffee, and tobacco.
Guess what was next on the list?
I think,
think shortly after that, they took
the tobacco off the yard.
And...
I say...
85% of men in prison smoke
cigarettes, drink coffee
and work out, 85% out of 100.
That's a lot, so the prison
is making a killing on tobacco
and coffee, of course.
And like I said, when they had
the weights and everything,
the workout kinda thing
going on, 'cause everybody
in prison was health and
fitness, even if yo ass
didn't want to, you had
to get yo ass in line
just in case some shit jumped off.
You'd be, you know, you'd be a little bit
in a better position to
take care of yourself.
So all races, it was
mandatory that you work out.
I love working out, so it
wasn't mandatory for me.
Shit, when I went to prison, now, you
couldn't keep me off the weights.
You know, that was my thing, you know?
And, but for some people,
it wasn't their thing
but they had no choice
because like I said,
what applies in there doesn't
apply out here and vice versa.
After they took
the tobacco,
you know, people was in
a uproar, man, because,
like I said, that's one of the number one
money factors in prison, man, is tobacco.
And once they took that, man,
it still didn't dawn on me
that they were trying to make
it hard instead of easy, man.
You know, they were trying to deter me
but I couldn't see it back
then, man, 'cause like I said,
I was lost in the politics of the shit.
And I had my own troubles in there
and I had my own troubles in the streets.
So it was like, damn, I dread,
when it's time for me
to parole and go home,
I dreaded going home, man, and then when
I did my bullshit on the
streets and got caught,
it's like, God, and to some degree
I dreaded going to prison.
Because of the bullshit
that came with it, you know,
and plus they took the
weights off the yard,
they took the tobacco
and I love, I used to...
Back in prison, they had
a Bugler rolling tobacco
and I was a Bugler
connoisseur, man, I'd roll
the hell out some Bugler cigarettes.
You know, I mastered it,
you know, I could roll one
behind my back, man, with one hand.
You know, and, shit, I took
my show on the road, man.
I took it to the streets,
man, and I was on the streets
goin' to the tobacco shop
back in the early 90s, man,
buying a can of Bugler
for like 20 bucks, man,
and coming with 200 papers.
And I'm rolling my ass off, man
and walking down the street.
I remember some LAPD officers
driving by lookin', 'cause it
looked like marijuana sticks
but it was just rolling tobacco.
But I rolled 'em like, like I said, like,
they look like joints.
You know, and I was on Bugler, man.
Even after they weren't
popular no more on the streets,
you know, 'cause people
started going to like regular
cigarettes, so I went from the Buglers
to the fuckin' Camel non-filters.
You know, 'cause that was another thing.
This mantra about being
in prison, you know,
everybody, you knew who was in prison
from what they smoked on the streets.
So if you see somebody
with a pouch of Bugler,
you knew that motherfucker was in prison.
If you see somebody with a
pack of Camel non-filters,
you knew he was from prison,
too, but it seemed like
in a higher levels, they was
doing a Camel non-filters.
In the Fire Camp, stuff like that,
they was doing the rolling tobacco.
And...
So I think my,
my seventh, eighth trip,
it started getting worse
and worse in there, man.
They start coming up with
all these guidelines,
all these rules and
all that bullshit, man,
They made it hard on you.
And I still couldn't see it.
You know, I still couldn't see
that they was really trying
to get a hold on people not
wanting to come back and forth
to prison, man, and in the
beginning, for me, man,
it was, you know, it was like
playing a cat and mouse game.
You know?
What I can get away with
while I'm in there, you know,
how can I out slick,
you know, the counselors
and the guards and all that kinda shit
by being this model inmate.
But really putting forth an effort, man.
But just not having
nothing to work with, man,
because they didn't give you
nothing viable in prison.
You know, I just knew what I
had comin' when I got there.
I knew what time count was, I
knew what jobs they kinda gave
out, you know, you doin'
poor, the kitchen worker.
Shit like that, education
and special services,
you know, that was it.
That's all, they, it was limited, what you
could do in prison, as
far as work, so I already
knew going in what I was gonna do, man.
Man, put me in the kitchen.
Yeah, put my ass right there in the back,
doing the pots and pans
so I can be out the way
and I could steal everything
I got my hands on, man.
And sell to back to the
fellas when I get there.
The bell peppers, the onions,
the mustard, whatever, man.
You know, I was in there surviving, man,
trying to survive, man.
'Cause it's hard in prison
when you're in there
by yourself and you don't have no support.
It's hard as hell and a lot of
people couldn't take it, man.
And they sunk.
So they get up into the black
market kinda thing in prison.
Cell phones, tobacco, drugs.
I didn't play that shit, I'm
like, man, fuck that shit.
I wanna go home when
it's my turn to go home
because everybody get a turn to go home.
I just didn't know all those
trips leading up to my 19th
that I didn't have a plan and
I wasn't prepared for home.
So even though I was a model
inmate, even though I did all
the self help classes, even
though I came in one way,
came out a different way,
I was still working with
the same information.
the same thing emotionally.
I was still working with
the same kid, mentally.
You know, I was just getting
older in age, you know,
as the trips came on, as you know,
from my first trip to like
the 15th trip, I was 18.
Then I found myself at 35 by my 18th trip.
And from 18 to 35, I was still
working with the same old
feelings, man, didn't
nothin' change from 18 to 35.
I don't give a fuck if I
went 1,000 times to prison.
Didn't nothin' change, man.
I was still working
with that same mindset.
Prison didn't have no psychiatry,
didn't have no counseling,
they didn't have all that,
the one on ones in there, man,
you was on your own
motherfuckin' own up in there.
And either your ass was gonna
swim or you was gonna sink.
And by, meaning sink,
you was gonna get yo ass
rolled up to the SNY yards
and all that kinda stuff, man.
All my 19 trips, I went
to general population.
I never put myself in a position
where I had to get rolled
up and moved off the yard,
man, because I didn't play that
shit, I knew what I had
to do and I did it well
up in prison, I just wish I
woulda had just as much success
as I had in prison by
walking that fine line,
like on the streets.
I couldn't walk that fine
line on the streets like
I did in there but I had
the guards hoverin' over me.
I had the inmates hoverin'
over me to make sure
that I didn't falter,
have a misstep because
in there, you have a
misstep, that's yo ass.
I'm not playing.
You talk about some shit
going on up in there, man,
by brothers not paying attention
and following the rules and
guidelines in there, man.
The consequences are
deep and they're heavy.
And...
So it took me, I think my
19th trip, man, to prison,
where I finally got it.
So what happened was nothin' changed from
the routine that I had
established from my first time
being in Fire Camp, I
still worked out every
motherfuckin' day, I still
did all the self-help classes.
I still did the church
and all that kinda stuff
and I still stayed out the
way, man, I stayed in my lane.
You know, and that didn't
change because it worked.
Now, I didn't have no
success on the street
with it but it worked in there, so, shit,
if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
And...
What happened was, man,
this time
when I paroled,
things started to click for me.
I kinda see where
the way the prison is set
up, it's set up for you,
not to succeed but to fail
because prison is what you
put into it is what you get up out of it.
If you don't put nothin' into it, then
yo ass ain't got nothin' comin'.
So having been sentenced to nine years,
waiting to present, it wasn't
just no in and out, back
and forth like I been, you
know, going up to the 18 times,
seven months, nine months,
three months, four months,
five months, two years, three
years, 60 months, four years.
It wasn't that in and out, back
and forth kinda shit, like,
now you see me, now you don't.
When they gave me that nine years with 80,
I really had to sit my ass down
and really take a look at
what was going on around me
all the time that I didn't
see the first 18 times.
I saw a lot of men come
in there, didn't put
a motherfuckin' thing into it
and when it's time for them
to get they turn to take they
ass home, scared to death.
'Cause they didn't have no
plan, they wasn't prepared
and I remember getting up in the morning
'cause they used to release us,
in prison, after breakfast sometimes.
So you have to be in R&R,
like, by 9:00 in the morning.
So they give you your
little parole clothes,
all that bullshit and
take you to the train,
the bus station, give you a little $200
and that's it, see ya, bon
voyage, good luck, godspeed.
And I remember being in a
TV room or the game room
or wherever the fuck I
happened to be at that time
and I see these men, you
know, being called to go home
and I used to watch 'em and
some of 'em be so scared
and so I could see the
despair written over they face
because they really didn't
do a motherfuckin' thing
while I was there, man, they
just went through the motions.
I went through the motions a
lot of times in the beginning.
Think the first 15
motherfuckin' trips for me,
I went through the motions.
Then I wonder why I didn't stand a chance
out here on the streets.
Shit.
If you want it, you got to
get it and I didn't see that
at the time, I know
how to work, I knew how
to get it when it came to
weight training, I love it.
I know how to get that, I
know everything, in and out
about training, man, about bodybuilding.
You know, shit, that's me.
Love it!
But the last trip I was just watching
and the more I paid
attention, the more things
started to click for me and
it came together for me.
And I saw how prison is not
designed to help yo ass.
It's not built to help
you succeed when you
get yo motherfuckin'
ass back on the streets.
Prison is there for you to
pay your debt to society,
for whatever the fuck you
did prior, on the streets
that got you in a judical
court system, that
got you sentenced to a place like that.
It's not there to do the
pep talks to help you.
Man, you got to pay yo
debt, whatever crime it is.
You know, so, it's not set up,
it's not designed as a
good place to wanna go.
You know, it's a place that,
even more so now, before I paroled,
this last time, man, they
took, they took so much stuff
and they changed the
rules so much, I vowed,
'cause it started, like I
said, I started really watching
and paying attention because
I was there for a long time.
It just wasn't no, in and
out, hop, skip and a jump.
I really sat, they sat
my ass down long enough
for me to really see what
was going on around me
and why it was so hard
for me to stay outta there
for me to stay successful
on the streets because I tried
to combine the two together
and they just don't mix,
it's like oil and water.
And I always tried to take
some of the good stuff from
prison and apply it on the
streets, but it never worked.
And I tried to take some of
the good morals and values
I was learning, take that shit,
man, they don't give a fuck
about that, how you was
raised and how good you are.
So I tried to be the model
inmate in prison but
they don't give a fuck
about no model inmate.
And I tried to be the model
citizen on the streets where
most characters, most cats,
man, they don't give a fuck
about no model, productive citizen
in a motherfuckin' crack house.
In the hood, they can
care less about that.
You better not be talking about what you
learned and what you gained.
Liable to get your throat cut,
'cause ain't nobody on that
page, ain't nobody trying
to hear that good shit.
Not from where I come from.
You better be about the hustle,
about the paper, about the money.
'Cause if it don't make
dollars, it don't make sense.
And...
Yeah, I was convinced of that one time,
but not no more, man, you know?
So what I did, man, my last
trip, man, I did what made my
motherfuckin' ass happy and
that was just to pay attention
and watch all the comings and
goings and kept my mouth shut
and did more observing, then I
realized why it never worked.
I realized now why
things never panned out,
why things never worked out.
Because I was applying the wrong methods
to the streets and vice versa.
So I got hooked up with the right people.
I took advantage of the
teachers, the instructors
that was there, I got all the information
I could and it was back and forth.
And when I paroled...
January, February, March, April, May.
I paroled May 17th, 2017.
Man, I ain't look back,
I ain't missed a beat.
Because for the first time
in my life, man, out of all
those motherfuckin' trips
to prison, I had a plan
and I was prepared, but you know what?
It might've took,
you know, those 18 times
prior just to get me
to that place where I
said, enough is enough
and I better do something
about my dire situation
because in the beginning
it wasn't a dire situation
until I got, until I started at 18
and then I went in at 43.
So when I was at 43, with that nine years,
I'm like, goddamn, man, it ain't no game,
it ain't no joke up in here, man.
This shit ain't no game,
it ain't no guarantee
I'm going home, I got the
PTSD, the longer yo ass stay
up in there, you gonna come
home with some kind of problems.
Ask a lifer that do 26 or 38
years and get his ass home.
It's gonna take him a
long time to get that shit
up out of his system, whatever it is.
And me doing six and a half years,
man, some of that stuff
is still seeping through
my pores, man, still running through me.
You know, I didn't know,
back and forth, in and out
that it just accumulated,
accumulated, accumulated, accumulated
and I been holding on to the stuff
for as long as I can remember.
Now, I'm finally able to
release it, but it's not easy.
It'll never be easy because I'll notice,
all the shit I been through in prison,
with not knowin', you know,
I been in some riots, man.
I been in with the fights and all that
and being close to knives
and all that bullshit
and the gunshots, I been
through all of that.
But for the life of me, when
I came home, I couldn't talk,
I didn't have nobody to
talk to about that stuff
I experienced in prison,
I don't give a fuck
if I went 1,000 times.
My 19 trips to prison and
every time I came home,
I didn't talk about that, nobody
wanted to hear about that.
So I kept that shit
bottled up inside of me,
all my experiences in prison.
So I didn't have no release.
So I'm walking around with
all that bullshit on my
shoulders, then I come on
the streets and I got to deal
with the family situation
and family dynamics,
not having a personal
relationships with nobody,
dealing with the crack
cocaine bullshit episode
and all that, so it was
just, I was just like
a walking time bomb.
And it took me a long time,
man, to see it for what it was.
You know, that's why it is
so imperative for me to talk
about this stuff, man,
because I've been holding
on to it for so long, it'll kill me.
And if I don't talk about
it, I'll have my ass
back in prison, it's inevitable.
'Cause that's all I know,
in and out, back and forth.
I don't know nothin' else.
(sirens blaring)
Shit, if I did, I'd practice
somethin' different.
It's like the home training,
man, what I was taught is just
what I was taught, give a fuck
about the wrong information.
It's all they have to offer me.
And I can live with that,
even with the mistakes, man.
I'm cool with that because
I knew sooner or later
there had to be a change come about.
But I knew the change was gonna
have to come from within me.
It started with my ass
and it was gonna with me.
I don't give a fuck who
guided me, who misled me
along the way, that's irrelevant.
Because I am responsible for me.
I'm responsible for me.
I got to take care of me,
I got to look out for me,
do the best I can for me,
'cause that's all I got is me.
Hell, no, I don't do a
perfect job, I wish I did.
But nothing beats a failure but a tribe.
And...
I hit those milestones,
you know, 50 years old,
finally got my driver's
license for the first time.
And I've been home
a little over three years,
that's a hell of a milestone.
You know, I think the
most I've ever stayed home
was maybe a little over two
years during my 19 trips.
Almost two years, I was able to, almost
able to stay home before
I had went right back.
And the last time, like I said
before, was two days, man.
So this is a milestone for
me, you know, I'm happy
where I'm at in my life.
It's never easy
dealing with reality when
I been shucking and jiving
and bobbin' and weavin' and
escaping it for so long,
finally getting to the place
or the point in my life
where I'm really able to
deal with it for what it is.
See it for what it is, life,
my experience and everything
that come about it,
that makes me who I am.
And...
It wasn't easy
overcoming prison
because my first impression
was, that was the one that got me.
That was the one that hooked me.
Which was the Fire Camps, the
weights and all that stuff,
the TV, the coffee and the
cigarettes and all that shit.
It was alluring, man, and it
was like a dream come true.
You know, and towards the end, the picture
was, you know, it changed
and when it changed in a prison settings,
I just wasn't capable of
changing with it at the time.
So I had to go back and
forth, I had to endure
some more shit, I had to do
it some more before my eyes
started to finally open to
see the reality of prison,
how it wasn't that no more,
it hasn't been like that
in a long time but that was
what I was going on, that's what
motivated me, knowing
what it used to be like
but it had changed before
my very eyes and it took me
a long time to see that change take place.
So anything that I do,
anything that I say,
you know, hopefully, it
doesn't have to take as long.
You know, but it seemed like
my experiences with life,
with drugs, with relationships,
with prison, with rehabs,
man, it didn't take the first trip
or the umpteenth motherfuckin' trip, man.
Even in my rehabs, I think
I've been to 30 programs
prior to, you know, just
leading up to here, man.
You know, 30 of the motherfuckers,
man, and I put my best
foot, I put my best foot.
I put my best foot forward
in all those 30 vain attempts
at trying to get my life
together from the crack, man.
Now, that's a hell of a story
right there, if you want me
to speak on that and it'd
be a pleasure to talk about
the rehabs, man, 'cause I
wasn't bullshittin' when I went
to get that help, I really
wanted that help, I really wanted
that change, I really
wanted to be that man
God created me to be.
Just like when I went to
prison, I didn't want to go
and I didn't want to leave
the same way I came in.
But I didn't know at the time, man,
that what I put into it is
what I got up out of it.
So I was just going through
the motions in the beginning
'cause that's what everybody
was doing in prison,
just going through the
motions, until they turn
came to go home again.
And I was just in line waiting
for my motherfuckin' turn
to go home but really didn't
change, really didn't put forth
an effort and then I wonder
why I went right back
over and over and I wonder why I
couldn't get up off that entanglement.
I wonder why I said, "Man,
when it got too hard out here,
"man, I don't give a fuck, man,
send my ass back to prison.
"What took you so long?"
'Cause I meant that.
Because what was abnormal
became normal for me.
It became a part of my
lifestyle, part of my character
trait, prison, you know, I
didn't wear it as no badge
of honor or no bullshit
like that but it was just
an intricate part of me.
And it took me a long
time to see it for what
it was and break those shackles.
You know?
And...
So I'm learning how to break
those shackles on the street,
man, with my mind, man,
being in a prison in my mind
out here on the streets, man.
You know, I see it for
what it is out here,
it's a beautiful day, I
love being free, I love
being home, I love putting
my best foot forward.
You know, put one foot in front
of the other, come what may.
Yeah, I make my mistakes,
shit, I wish I was perfect
but I'm not perfect but I
do the motherfuckin' best
I can with what I'm working
with and I can live with that.
I don't know about nobody
else, I'm not no quitter.
I'm a fighter and I wanna be
more than just a survivor.
I want a life worth living,
man, and so far so good.
I'm realizing that that dream,
one of those unspoken prayers,
I mean having my own place.
Now, I'm working on getting
transportation but there's some
things I have to do in
order, you know, just to get,
to get back to where I
would be more comfortable
with being in this setting
because it's a struggle.
You know, it's a struggle for a brother
who dropped out in the 10th grade,
who don't have no work
history, some more shit
that's stacked up against,
it ain't easy comin' up from
under all of that, plus you
add the prison setting on top
of that and the shit I learned
in there, man, it's almost
impossible for a brother to
surface from up under all that
bullshit but I managed to.
So, I know I'm something special.
I know I'm somebody to be reckoned with.
I know I'm not your
average motherfuckin' Joe.
Thank God, 'cause I see
it for what it is in me.
I don't care how nobody
else see me or what they
take is on me, it don't matter.
It's what I think and care
about myself that matters today.
And I love me and I'll do
everything in my power to make
sure that I keep on putting
one foot in front of the other.
I'm tired.
I'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired.
So now it's all about action.
Ready or not, prepared or
not, I'm going for what I know
and that's broke, thank you.